- [Voiceover] Let's see if
we can calculate what 5/6
plus 1/4 is, and to help us,
I have a visual representation of 5/6,
and a visual representation of 1/4.
Notice I have this whole whole,
I guess you could say,
broken up into one, two,
three, four, five, six
sections, and we've
shaded in five of them,
so this is 5/6,
and then down here, we have another whole,
and we have one out of the
four equal sections shaded in
so this is 1/4, and I want to add them,
and I encourage you at any
point, pause the video,
and see if you could
figure it out on your own.
Well, whenever we're adding
fractions, we like to think
in terms of fractions that
have the same denominator,
and these clearly don't
but in order to rewrite them,
with a common denominator,
we just have to think of a
common multiple of six and four,
and ideally, the smallest
and the way that I like to do that is
I like to take the larger
of the two, which is six,
and then think about its multiples.
So I could first think about six itself.
Six is clearly divisible
by six, but it's not
perfectly divisible by
four, so now, let's multiply
by two, so then we get to 12.
12 is divisible by both six and four.
So 12 is a good common denominator here.
It's the least common
multiple of six and four.
So we can rewrite both of
these fractions as something
over 12.
So, something over 12
plus something,
plus something over 12
is equal to.
Now, there's a bunch of ways to tackle it,
but what I want to do is I
just want to visualize it here
on this drawing.
So, if I go,
if I were to go from,
if I were to go from six equal sections
to 12 equal sections,
which is what I'm doing
if I'm going from six
in the denominator to 12
in the denominator.
I'm essentially multiplying
each of these sections by,
or, I'm essentially multiplying
the number of sections
I have by two,
or I'm taking each of
these existing sections
and I'm turning them into two sections,
so let's do that.
Let's do that.
Let me see if I can do it pretty neatly,
so, I can do it a little
bit neater than that.
So, it'll look like that.
And,
whoops.
Let me do this one.
I want to divide them
fairly close to evenly.
I'm doing it by eye so it's
not going to be perfect.
So, and you have that one.
And then last not,
last but not least,
you have that one there, and then notice,
I had six sections, but
now I've doubled the number
of sections.
I've turned the six sections
into 12 sections by turning
each of the original six
into two, so now I have
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12 sections.
So if I have 12 sections
now, how many of those 12
are now shaded in?
Instead of having five
of the six, I now have
10 of the 12 that are shaded in.
So I now have 10/12.
5/6 is the same thing as 10/12.
Another way you could
have thought about that,
to go from six to 12, I
had to multiply by two,
so then I have to do the
same thing in the numerator.
Five times two is 10.
But hopefully you see
that those two fractions
are equivalent,
that I didn't change
how much is shaded in,
I just took each of the
original six and I turned it
into two, or I multiplied
the total number of sections
by two to get 12,
and then instead of having 5/6,
I now have 10/12 shaded in.
Now let's do the same thing with the four,
with the 1/4.
Right here, I've depicted 1/4,
but I want to turn this into
something over 12.
So to turn it into something over 12,
each section has to be
turned into three sections.
So let's do that.
Let's turn each section
into three sections.
So, that's one, two, and three.
So then I have one, two,
and three.
I have,
I think you can see where this is going.
One,
two and three.
I have one, two, and three.
And so notice, all I did is I multiplied,
before I had four equal sections.
Now I turned each of those
four sections into three
sections, so now I have 12 equal sections.
And I did that, essentially,
by multiplying the number
of sections I had by three.
So now what fraction is shaded in?
Well, now, this original
that was one out of the
four, we can now see is three
out of the 12 equal sections.
It's now three out of
the 12 equal sections,
and so what is this going to be?
Well, if I have 10/12,
and I'm adding it to 3/12,
well how many twelfths do I have?
I'm going to have 13/12.
And you could see it
visually over here as well.
Up here in green, I have 10/12 shaded in.
Each of these boxes are a twelfth.
Let me write that down.
Each of these boxes are 1/12.
That's 1/12.
This is 1/12.
So how many twelfths do I have shaded in?
I have the 10 that are shaded in in green,
and then I have an 11/12,
a 12/12 and then finally,
the 13/12 is one way to think about it.